el alemán robert sabe que dibuja una
sonrisa acoge en berlín los otros
ministros de energía de los países del
g7 y por primera vez todos los miembros
están de acuerdo en abandonar
progresivamente el carbón como fuente
energética
por la promesa que hacemos es que los
sectores eléctricos de los siete países
serán mayoritariamente descarbonizado de
aquí a 2035 y carbón y sietes android
para lograr su objetivo los países del
g7 se comprometieron a dejar de
financiar los proyectos fósiles en el
extranjero este 2022 hasta el momento
japón se oponía a este acuerdo como
mantuvo en la cob 26 celebrada en
noviembre pasado en glasgow me
congratulo de la unidad que ha
demostrado el g7 para ir más lejos que
el año pasado comprometiéndose a césar
la financiación internacional de los
combustibles fósiles de aquí a finales
de año en off des y en esta reunión las
siete mayores potencias industriales
también aceptaron desarrollar las
tecnologías y políticas necesarias para
pasar a energías limpias en estocolmo
donde debe celebrarse la próxima cumbre
de la tierra los militantes climáticos
esperan algo más que promesas
de los dirigentes del mundo entero van a
reunirse para reflexionar sobre los
próximos 50 años
espero que paren de mentir sobre sus
acuerdos y sobre lo que han hecho los
últimos 50 años sin fronda las cifras la
primera conferencia de naciones unidas
sobre el medio ambiente se celebró hace
50 años también aquí en suecia donde el
2 y 3 de junio los líderes mundiales
buscarán soluciones al cambio climático
la pérdida de biodiversidad y la
contaminación